hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my full Black Panther review
hopefully you've had a chance to see the
movie we're gonna be getting into
specifics probably one of the best
Marvel movies that they've ever made not
without its flaws and from what I've
seen most people are in agreement on
what those flaws are it emits like these
really amazing performances from amazing
actors and all these really mind-blowing
visuals it's really the conventions of
superhero movies that drag down certain
parts of the film if you're just finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we have
so much infinity war stuff that's gonna
be happening now there's a weekly
giveaway that I'm doing that I'll talk
about at the end of the video too so
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen Black Panther oh wait just a second
so here we go starting with the really
cool stuff a little bit James Bond a
little bit Shakespeare Hamlet in my
opinion but the James Bond stuff was
really funny because he feels a lot like
James Bond the way that they write the
character but they also literally
reference James Bond during the film
those funny American films that father
used to watch so much the reason why
this is key from a story standpoint and
also for future black panther movies is
it makes him a jetsetter he can go
anywhere what is one of the conventions
of a James Bond film as you literally
travel all over the world to different
places in the different movies so it
just opens up a world of storytelling
that you wouldn't get before the way
that that can become a problem for films
like spider-man who's mostly central to
New York City so the other beauty of
black panther 2 is that it's literally
set at a location that you've never been
to before in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so there's like a whole half of
the globe that they can travel all over
that you wouldn't see in the normal
Marvel films who are mostly American
characters or the films that are set in
outer space really the James Gunn and
the Marvel cosmic universe is doing the
same thing to broaden the Marvel
mythology in the way that Black Panther
is just a whole different location that
you mostly didn't see for those first 10
years even in the Thor films which take
place in outer space Kevin Feige even
said that they pumped extra money over
what they would normally pump into a
movie to build the world of Wakanda to
just like give you its full majesty and
I feel like that translates well by
panthers line is very key this never
gets old
so of course Chad
bowsman is fantastic as black panther he
plays king black panther amazingly the
story of him ascending to the throne the
Prince to Kings storyline does fall prey
to some superhero movie conventions so
that pulls the film down a little bit
because it asks you to make a couple
leaps like oh let's pretend that he's
dead we know that he's gonna be alive
that in the fact that the character just
doesn't have a lot of natural flaws like
I said he plays King black panther
perfectly he has this very regal way of
holding himself even when he's not sure
of himself like he doubts himself
through the film but through it all he
seems like this unstoppable force there
is no point in the film where you
believe like he is not going to be
victorious so I've seen a couple of
hilarious complaints even from people
that loved the film that say we want to
see a black panther with a few more
flaws but it just it's really hard to
accomplish that when you need someone to
be a king on the level that he is so I
can understand why people have some
problems with that aspect of the
character but it's not like Robert
Downey jr. Tony Stark you can't make
Black Panther as a character as
despicable as Tony Stark was during the
first Iron Man film there's so much that
we can say about Michael B Jordans
character also falls prey to a couple of
superhero conventions but by about
halfway through the film when he gets to
see his father in the Dajjal eeeh and
you have that cry moment that's what
brings it all together
that is the most important part of the
film for his character because up to
that point he just feels like a standard
Marvel villain or something out of a
spike Lee movie with a little bit of
Shakespeare thrown in but a lot of the
credit towards crystallizing his
character also goes to that child actor
that played the young version of kill
monger and his father played by Sterling
Kay Brown they really brought that scene
together so by the end of the film when
they're sitting there and he's sort of
bleeding out you really feel for his
character the way that you felt for the
Loki character in the way that they
wrote what happened to his father like
his backstory is key and yes they did
change the comics to do that but because
it totally worked I was totally fine
with it usually in retrospect like when
they changed something as cool as long
as it works in the moment the secret
weapon of the movie both figuratively
and literally is the Sheree character
the little sister that makes fun of her
big brother who just happens to be the
most powerful King on the earth
in this amazing tech genius with a sense
for style in pop culture that enables
her to crack wise like Iron Man or
Spider Man would like you can actually
see each of them just trying to out quip
each other in a conversation well
actually he's the boss I just pay for
everything and design everything Lupita
deny both amazing characters I'm a
little bummed about how good Lupita was
in the movie because now it's like well
they're very clearly setting her up as
the love interest for black panther how
are they going to work storm in when
they get the x-men characters martin
freeman is an amazing actor who feels a
little odd in the film like he's just
meant to be the connection to the wider
world
he literally works for the CIA now he's
gonna become something of a liaison to
black panther because he's opening up
the borders and giving everybody access
to their technology so while the movie
writes him to be a very important
character it just feels like he doesn't
rise to the level of some of the other
characters in the film so amazing actor
in a slightly under written part but
Andy Serkis obviously great is the
mystery of Ilyn he does a great job of
being despicable like that's his role in
the film be the villain that only cares
about selling to the highest bidder
doesn't care about culture doesn't care
about history where I was on the
opposite end of that spectrum all Eric
kill monger cares about is his history
and his heritage kind of a bummer to see
him go out but I did like the way that
they retro actively explained that age
of Ultron scene where he explains how he
got the brand it goes all the way back
to kill mongers father if that wasn't
clear all the vibranium that kill monger
had stolen from Wakanda when we get to
age of Ultron was actually done so with
the help of kill mongers father
that's why Quinta Chaka came to talk to
him in that opening credits scene
because kill mongers father was trying
to use claw to arm all the oppressed
people all over the world the way that
they tried to do later in the film in a
much more militaristic way I would say
Winston Dukes mbaku never quite rises to
the level of kill monger or Nakia and
Akoya his characters he falls prey to a
lot of superhero conventions where it's
like okay we understand he's just
supposed to be an obstacle for Black
Panther to overcome on his way to the
throne he becomes a lot more fun in that
final act of the film but he's barely a
character loved the Spike Lee movie
within the movie all the Oakland stuff
like that's how they try to tie it into
or real-world setting like look this is
how Black Panther is a character can
affect these people that are living in
America but I think a lot of people
wanted them to focus more on that like
what does this actually mean for the
people that we see running around in all
these Marvel movies so they wanted it to
be more political but because it's a
Marvel movie it needs to be more of a
superhero movie so I can understand why
different people want different things
from the movie but it does a really good
job of trying to address real world
issues and then explaining what Black
Panthers going to be doing about that
going forward in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I saw that a lot of people were
down on that opening narration
explaining what vibranium was that's
what that was for just to explain why it
was so important how it got to earth
because it's a big MacGuffin of the film
in a very big deal for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but if you've never
read a Marvel comic book just trying to
explain what vibranium is and how it can
be used in all these different aspects
of life how it's not just a metal can be
a little dense so I was totally fine
with that opening narration scene you
even see Captain America's plane when
they're talking about all the world
history that's happened like they do the
world war two scenes the Kendricks
soundtrack was next-level that's
probably gonna be the other biggest
thing that people talk about after the
film I've been looking for vinyl
pre-orders but I haven't seen any pop-up
yet the only other minor complaint about
the film is that final big CG battle
that he gets into with kill monger it's
weird that at this point in Marvel
history they haven't got to the point
where they can really do a CG battle
like that in a convincing way like it
still looks a little cartoonish at
moments when they both are in full
costume fighting inside the great Mound
but again all Marvel complaints I feel
like they don't ruin the film at all and
I do I love the hilarious complaint
about Black Panthers character that he's
too perfect which i think is a very
understandable thing like I explained
like he has to be king you can't make
him as despicable as Tony Stark was
before he became the character that he
is now so once you have a chance to see
it everybody let me know what you
thought of it in the comments below
obviously there's all kinds of stuff
that we can talk about for the Black
Panther sequels there's no way that
they're not gonna do a sequel during
phase four the only thing that we know
about films past 2020 is that we might
get x-men characters so all bets are off
after 2020 but we have Captain Marvel we
haven't
he wore Avengers 4 so just leave all
your bonus video requests in the
comments below
but obviously most of my videos after
the next couple of weeks will be
focusing more on Avengers related stuff
on Captain Marvel and the stuff going
forward there is supposed to be a new
infinity war promo later tonight so
obviously I'll do a video for that but
I'll probably be posting late as long as
you have alerts enabled you will see the
video so make sure you click that bell
if you happen already but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner mr. Rogers please private message
me so I can get your contact details
it's for the Infinity Gauntlet but if
you want movie tickets that's fine too
I mean it's basically the same value
there'll be a new round of the giveaway
when I post new Marvel later tonight so
while you wait for everything click here
for my black panther post credits scene
video and click here to rewatch that
infinity war trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]